[Música]
hola bienvenidos a 5 minutos con
france24 y rf y transmitieron en directo
el pasado 3 de abril el lanzamiento del
astronauta francés se toma pesqué desde
el centro espacial kennedy en florida en
eeuu para dar inicio a su segunda misión
en órbita desde entonces está en la
estación espacial internacional en una
misión denominada alfa que hace tomar a
diario como es vivir en el espacio qué
actividades tienen los astronautas y los
cosmonautas en sus misiones ustedes van
a tener acceso a todos los detalles
porque cada mes toma pesqué nos dará
noticias desde el espacio a través de un
vídeo diario nos contará sobre sus
actividades a bordo en la estación
espacial internacional y nosotros desde
tierra les mostraremos y por supuesto
aprenderemos cómo funciona y para qué
sirve esta estación
a todos hoy toma pesqué desde la
estación espacial internacional para
france24 puede que hayan seguido mi
primera misión entonces que ha cambiado
y en la estación hay muchas cosas que
han cambiado por 33 fuera voy a tratar
de mostrarles algunas de ellas una de
las cosas que ha cambiado es que estoy
en el laboratorio columbus y la agencia
espacial europea encima de mí ahora
tenemos un espacio para dormirse detrás
de esta fachada hay como enormes
armarios y es del tamaño de una cabina
telefónica actualmente tenemos más
tripulación a bordo de la estación así
que instalamos un tipo de cama extra en
columbus así que como trabajo en europa
tanto dormir en ropa cuando está
terminado por el momento lo utilizamos
pero eso es parte de las cosas que
pasamos enteros incluso en columbus
bienvenidos al laboratorio japonés la
joya vivo a bordo de la estación
espacial es probablemente el módulo más
grande de la novedad que quería
mostrarles aquí es este equipo que
todavía está organizando en los armarios
se llama el speed life in black box y es
una cabina completamente sellada en el
que podemos realizar experimentos que no
contaminan como por ejemplo en células
madre como en pequeños animales así que
este es el centro neurálgico de la
ciencia a bordo en esta sesión antes
teníamos una propuesta como esta en el
laboratorio estadounidense ahora tenemos
dos esto es mucho más grande ha visto
mucha acción muchos experimentos en las
últimas semanas y así seguirá siendo
durante toda la ocasión
otra de las novedades está aquí este es
el módulo que llamamos blood sweat lote
número 3 aquí es donde se encuentran los
paños de la expansión y vamos a instalar
no sólo nuevos baños que son los
causaremos transmisiones de exploración
sino que también hemos mejorado todos
estos cables todo esto es para el
procesamiento del agua a bordo de la
gestión espacial de procesar hemos agua
llegamos al 90 por ciento un poco más
incluso de reciclaje de agua es
importante para nosotros porque no
podemos abastecernos de la tierra
permanentemente y es importante para la
tierra porque podremos aplicar esta
tecnología en lugar extraordinario
potable que es de más difícil acceso así
que hoy gracias a todo este complicado
equipo podemos llegar a reciclar casi el
95 del agua y eso también es nuevo son
mejorados
ahora estamos en el laboratorio
estadounidense que llamamos simplemente
el laboratorio es el corazón de la
estación esto no es algo que haya
cambiado pero es algo a lo que no
teníamos acceso en la primera misión 10
es la mejor ventana que tenemos en la
estación especial la cúpula es genial
para las vistas laterales pero para las
vistas verticales venimos a la misión no
puede tomar ninguna foto desde aquí
porque desafortunadamente esta ventana
está bloqueada la estaban usando para un
experimento científico durante seis
meses centenario y está disponible para
nosotros y nos gusta mucho tomar fotos
desde aquí ya van a ver lo increíble que
es la vista
impresionante es todo por ahora recuerde
que cada mes el astronauta toma pesqué
nos dará detalles de cómo es vivir en el
espacio y los avances de su misión
ustedes los podrán ver solamente aquí en
france24 siga con nosotros
[Música]